hello good morning this is sky news
breakfast live from chemical near
poland's main border crossing with
ukraine as the stream of refugees
escaping the fighting continues we'll
bring you the latest throughout the
morning as the conflict enters its 10th
day
and will report on the growing
humanitarian crisis from both sides of
the border
president zielinski criticizes nato for
not implementing a no-fly zone over
ukraine as russia continues to assault
the northern
today the alliance has given the green
light to the bombing of ukrainian cities
and villages by refusing to create a
no-fly zone
i'm live in western ukraine in la viv
tens of thousands of people are once
again expected to arrive in this city
today some of them will flee across the
border and others will stay in shelters
like this one
russia blocks as access to facebook and
twitter as some foreign media outlets
spend reporting in the country
55 million pounds raised in one day by
uk charities as hundreds of thousands
donate to help people fleeing the wall
and in other news tributes are paid to a
cricketing icon shane warren who has
died at the age of 52.
and later we'll be discussing today's
front pages with the journalists and
broadcasters afla hagan and thomas
copeland
[Music]
hello good morning as ukrainians wake up
to the 10th day of the russian invasion
their president has accused nato of
weakness and lack of unity vladimir
zelinski voiced his anger at the
organization's refusal to implement a
no-fly zone over his country but in the
last few moments russian media is
reporting that the russian defense
ministry will open humanitarian
corridors for residents of mariopol
we'll bring you more on that as we get
it
this comes as a large explosion lit up
the night sky in chernyhiv and ukrainian
officials say a third round of peace
talks could take place this weekend
let's look at the key points well we're
expecting president zielinski to speak
to the u.s senate this afternoon at
around 2 30 uk time
russia is attacking a number of cities
chonahev in the northeast has faced a
number of strikes at least 47 people are
known to have died there so far
meanwhile russia's communications
regulator has blocked facebook and
twitter for what it's claimed was
restricted access to russian media on
all platforms
and it comes as refugees continue to
flee to neighboring countries well over
a million people have left so far sally
lockwood has this report
bombing in the northern city of
chernahiv has intensified
thousands of residents spending another
long night in underground shelters
you can hear the man who filmed this on
his mobile phone say this is absolutely
terrifying
moscow denies targeting civilian areas
but in the village of bashiv less than
40 miles from the capital kiev
these decimated apartment blocks tell a
different story
ukraine has been plunged into a living
hell in less than two weeks
and in a nighttime address to the nation
a war-weary president accused nato of
not doing enough
all the people who die from this day
forward will also die because of you
because of your weakness because of your
lack of unity
today the alliance has given the green
light to the bombing of ukrainian cities
and villages by refusing to create a
no-fly zone
russian bombardments have stepped up in
cities across ukraine
smoke rising from these warehouses just
12 miles from kiev
in his latest address president putin
said there are no bad intentions towards
our neighbors
[Music]
but this is what ukrainians are seeing
a missile exploding over blogger nikita
dominikov as he updated his followers
ukraine's president wants to close the
country's airspace to save its citizens
from attacks like this
but a no-fly zone has once again been
ruled out by the u.s secretary of state
the only way to actually implement
something like a no-fly zone
is to send nato planes into ukrainian
airspace and to shoot down russian
planes and that
could lead to a full-fledged war
a third round of talks between ukraine
and russia will be held over the weekend
there's been no breakthrough so far
but a tentative agreement for safe
humanitarian corridors which is
something
why did i leave today because it's
terrifying neither is the threat of a
nuclear explosion troops are approaching
kiev that's why there's a card like this
people just want to live
it's a devastating sight to witness
another father sending his family to
safety while he stays to fight
this war now into a second week
is wreaking havoc and heartbreak on a
nation
sally lockwood sky news
well over the last few days we've seen a
number of companies pulling out of
russia and we've seen
a number of financial sanctions but in
the last few moments paypal has
announced that it is now adding itself
to that list it is suspending all
services in russia so no paypal
ability to pay for things in russia
well i'm here on the polish side of the
border you can see people gathering
around some makeshift braziers that
they've got going on here it is a really
freezing cold morning this morning a lot
of people here behind me have slept in
an oldest used tesco's building
overnight they're being offered warm
drinks and warm food while they're
waiting for transport on to their next
location and many of those will have
come from lev in ukraine where our
europe correspondent adam parsons is
adam what's the situation there this
morning
cold uh as you just said jane it's uh
it's snowing it's going to stay like
this over the course of the day and once
again lev is bracing itself for an
influx of people it's very hard to know
how many people come into this city
every day i've seen estimates ranging
from thirty thousand
to
a hundred thousand now just to put that
in some kind of context when we look at
another migrant story we're very
familiar with which is migrants crossing
the the english channel it's estimated
last year 28 000 people made that
journey in boats
more than that number come into this
city lev every day at the moment by the
most conservative estimate
and the city frankly is struggling to
cope with them it's doing an
extraordinary job of resilience and
creating shelters like this one uh this
is a an ad hoc
shelter for displaced people uh we're
gonna go and talk to some of those
people later on partly because the
person who actually owns that building
has asked us to he thinks it's his duty
he thinks it's their duty to tell their
story uh to the world and ukraine i
think is desperate that people know what
is happening
here uh it is that that combination that
we talked about of resilience on the one
hand and then increasing weariness on
the other because as you go into the
city you see long lines of people who
are making that difficult choice do they
flee do they come to poland or or head
maybe to to hungary slovakia romania
moldova mainly to poland there's a train
line that goes from lev uh over to to
near where you are
on on the polish border or do they stay
here do they maybe stay in the view of a
big city do they try and get to
areas
around it those of course are generally
the women and the children
the men
are
signing up in huge numbers to volunteer
to join the armed forces and we have
seen yesterday we saw hundreds and
hundreds of people joining a queue
outside a recruitment uh office
in order to just sign up and to get
effectively put their name on the list
not everybody who's signing up is
actually just straight getting on a bus
and
doing some training we met a man who's
actually dotted around signing up in
different places desperate
to serve his country and that uh i think
that a sort of esprit de corps comes
through from so many conversations that
you are having with people
here in ukraine they think they are
going to win this war they think they
will repel russia they see the same
pictures that we that we see or
once again you hear this they think they
should die trying it's an incredible
sort of
intoxicating feeling amongst many of uh
particularly the the men here you don't
see very many women signing up although
i should say there's a lot of women in
the ukrainian uh armed forces an army
that is all was already 200 000 strong
third biggest army in europe after
russia
and france and has hundreds of thousands
of reservists but of course pitched
against them as a russian military
machine vast
numerous although as we've seen from
that column heading towards keith
lumbered by some pretty unreliable
machinery
and that that battle between the
absolute determination of the ukrainian
people and this russian military might
is leading
to all of these ghastly things that
we've seen in whether it's in in kharkiv
whereas it's on the outsides of of kiev
and in maripol which is now we're
hearing about this offer of a
humanitarian corridor being put in there
uh and the tension that you clearly see
in places like a
and in the heart of kiev where they
await
a russian attack ukrainians
like so many of us simply don't know
what is going to happen
they don't know what vladimir putin's
plan is they are going to resist but it
is that sense of of nervousness and of
not knowing the future that i think
energizes some of them that exhausts and
terrifies many others
adam thanks so much for that
well war is raging in ukraine for now a
tenth day as russian troops besiege and
bombard cities let's bring you an
overview of how the conflict is playing
out across the country
well the un atomic watchdog has warned
that the world narrowly averted a
nuclear catastrophe after russia's
attack on the zaparizia power station
responsible for 20 percent of ukraine's
electricity
elsewhere in the country russian forces
are now advancing on the city of mikalev
close to the crucial economic hub of
odessa
in the north just outside the capital
seven people including two children were
reportedly killed in a strike in a
village on the outskirts of kiev
authorities in borodyanska say that they
fear a hundred people may be buried
under rubble after an airstrike and the
attacks are continuing to target the
capital kiev
but in the last few minutes the ministry
of defense has issued an update on
ukraine
and they are saying that the overall
rate of russian air artillery strikes
observed over the last 24 hours has been
lower than in previous days ukraine
continues to hold the key cities of
kharkiv chennahev and mariapol there
have been reports of street fighting in
sumi it's highly likely that all four
cities are encircled by russian forces
russian forces are probably advancing on
the southern port of mikalev there is a
realistic possibility that some forces
will attempt to circumvent the city to
prioritize progression towards odessa
and we've also heard in the last few
minutes of this humanitarian corridor
that is being opened up from mario pal
and we believe that russian forces have
now paused their attacks to allow people
to get out of that city well i'm joined
now by the economic secretary to the
treasury john glenn and this news that
there is now some kind of humanitarian
corridor possibly opening up out of
mario paul it is encouraging isn't it
yes it is uh it's obviously uh very
welcome um but uh set within the context
of
all that we've uh heard over the last
week and seen
uh from your brave reporters across the
region
i i i mean there is
only one way that this can really
definitively be dealt with and that is
for russia to withdraw and to come to
terms with the fact that this is uh an
illegal war and the world is outraged
but this humanitarian route is welcome
and it comes alongside endeavors by
many countries to try and find
supportive measures
to help the ukrainian people at this
difficult time
but those supportive measures it's been
made very clear hasn't it from the uk
from the eu and nato don't include a
no-fly zone uh and we've had another
statement from president vladimir
zelinsky overnight he said that uh
everyone who dies will die because of
you as well talking about those
countries that will not help with a
no-fly zone do you regret that that
stands do you regret the fact that we
are not helping
well i think everyone's hearts go out to
the ukrainian people as they bravely
come to terms with this aggression from
russia but we do have to
think carefully about how we deal with
the reality
of the escalation that would clearly be
at risk of ensuring if we uh supported
in that way and as uh the secretary of
state lincoln said in the clip that you
shared a few minutes ago uh that would
clearly uh be construed as an act of war
and would lead to an escalation and who
knows where that might end so of course
one's incredibly sympathetic the british
government's incredibly sympathetic and
is doing everything it can to offer
practical support outside
of that no-fly zone request but
that escalation risk is obviously very
real and one that nato will be very
aware of
having said that president putin's
forces hit a nuclear power plant
yesterday how much more escalation do
you need
well of course the world condemns that i
mean this was a a new uh type of warfare
i think there's increasing evidence that
putin's military are targeting civilians
or certainly being very indiscriminate
in the way that they're prosecuting this
illegal war
and the use of
attack on a nuclear facility the largest
in europe i believe is obviously hugely
concerning and it is to be condemned and
that's why across all of putin's
activities here in the ukraine we can
see that that we've got to scrutinize it
very carefully and the icc is looking at
the instances of of potential war crimes
um but uh this is a
nasty
military uh war that is
really uh you know beyond anything that
many people thought are possible of
putin now i i'm here in salisbury four
years ago uh he uh attacked uh some of
my constituents i've been very aware of
what he's capable of but i mean what
he's done uh in the ukraine is a new
level of aggression and uh this is an
illegal war and the way he's prosecuting
it is true to our worst fears of what
putin is capable of
but but given that and given what we
know about the way that president putin
operates
the conservative party has continued to
take an awful lot of money from russian
donors over the years hasn't it now in
hindsight do you think that was a
mistake
well i think uh all donations have to
comply
with the law and so
the the the law has always been uh held
to with all donations to all political
parties
[Music]
and we've taken very strong action
over the
last few weeks i'm the city minister
we've worked very closely with our
allies in the us and the eu to be
aligned on the interventions that we've
taken in our
financial system we work closely with
the bank of england and regulators to
make sure that we've frozen out the
russian businesses and
economic actors and we've seen that
reflected in the
loss of the
ruble's value um the fact that the
russian stock exchange hasn't been able
to open for over a week and just last
night the foreign secretary brought
forward new measures to allow us to move
more swiftly to deal with those entities
that will be sanctioned so we are
looking at every single option across
whole
range of matters across the economy
banning access to insurance
and doing everything we can to
reduce the uh the scope for uh economic
activity of the putin regime and that
does mean targeting those that have
enabled him to continue in power all
these years
would it would it lead to the
conservative party giving back some of
the donations that it's accepted over
the years
well as i said all those donations and
all donations to all political parties
have to comply with the law and i mean i
i can't speak to individual
donations or to individuals i mean what
i what i can say is that all of those
donations to all political parties have
to comply with the law
okay
good to talk to you today uh john glenn
mp chief secretary to the treasury thank
you very much for joining us
now g7 foreign ministers has said those
responsible for russian military attacks
on civilians in ukraine must be held
accountable amid reports of the use of
cluster bombs and other weapons well i'm
joined now by the ukraine and russian
senior researcher at human rights watch
europe and central asia division julia
gorbanova who is currently in the
western ukrainian city of lev uh good to
talk to you today julia
how are you what is the situation live
at the moment as you know
hi um it's a it's it's quiet in terms of
fighting um but as you know uh there are
thousands and thousands of people
fleeing from other parts of ukraine that
have been affected by very intensive
fighting over the last week
um and uh
we're seeing a lot of a lot of people
here that are extremely traumatized that
have witnessed
their houses
destroyed
some of them had
people in their family killed or injured
and
just we're seeing enormous civilian
suffering here on the ground
we heard allegations um made public
yesterday about the raping of pregnant
women in in the donbass region
was that something that you would human
rights which were aware of
we do not have any confirmed reports of
that however in any conflict uh sexual
violence gender-based violence in
general usually spikes
um and we we continue to to to monitor
um the the situation specifically
because that's something unfortunately
that tends to happen quite a lot uh in
an armed conflict
i mean when we look at at human rights
the bombing of civilians shooting
civilians in their cars is clearly a
breach of their human rights and
what about what russia's new tactic
appears to be this surrounding of cities
and placing the civilians under siege
it's it's
extremely disturbing uh to see because
we um
we have recently published a report on
the situation in haikov and what we're
seeing in haikov is that uh in violation
of international law that governs
conduct of war
russian forces have been
indiscriminately shelling
civilian areas so areas where there are
no military targets
they are populated by
regular people by civilians and
you know a lot of people have died or
been injured as a result vital
infrastructure have been damaged or
destroyed um we've spoken to the
office of the mayor of haikov just uh
two days ago and he told us that you
know hundreds of buildings hundreds of
residential buildings have been uh
severely damaged
or otherwise damaged and you know people
lost their
their homes um but also um the
educational facilities have been damaged
those schools and the kindergartens of
dozens of those have been uh destroyed
by artillery strikes or
shelling
and indiscriminate shelling is
prohibited by international law
and use of certain types of weapons such
as cluster munitions is prohibited by
international law for
the reason that uh some of these weapons
cannot be targeted precisely so even if
a warring party is trying to hit a
military target they're very likely to
also
affect civilians because the area of
impact is so large so for instance with
cluster munitions a lot of um
submunitions not do not explode upon
impact
and they basically spread around in a
very large area the size of a football
field roughly and effectively become
mines that can explode later
and we've seen that happening in
early stages of the conflict
when um
there were intensive hostilities and
intensive fighting in the bus in 2014
2015 2016 and unfortunately we're seeing
same tactics being used now and
civilians suffer enormously and we are
very concerned that as these hostilities
will escalate uh there will be more um
violations of international law in terms
of uh
weapons that are used uh ill treatment
of pows
gender-based violence and sexual
violence and other
other violations that
affect civilians bravely
it is a gloomy picture
julia gorbachovner thank you very much
for joining us from uh live
well as ukrainians flee their homes
communities in the uk are pulling
together to provide aid for those
affected by the invasion
in just one day charities have raised 55
million pounds katarina vertotsi has
this report
bag after bag
box after box out of incredible
suffering has come this moving human
kindness
cardigan
tom jackson and sister jenny hancock
have family in ukraine and set up this
aid collection point in a local workshop
for days now there's been endless
donations
it's been incredibly moving and we're
just really proud to be a part of it to
be honest
we've been working with the ukrainian
center in manchester but at the moment
we've completely swamped them out and
now there they've got this bottleneck
now where they're struggling to get
things over to
to the ukraine um
or even poland if there is some haulish
company out there who would be willing
to
accept or accept the goods and get it to
the polish border where it's desperately
needed that would be just what that
would just be amazing we need a trolley
we've got the trolleys
people have been moved to act in ways
both big and small
charity dec saw 55 million pounds raised
in just 24 hours
this coffee shop is donating a day's
profits
people are seeking ways to just act and
to to show kindness and i think that
just you know being able to purchase a
coffee and have a quick chat
but whilst doing good is so meaningful
to so many um it's overwhelming how
generous people are
generous and aware i loved the messages
of staying strong i've seen some
fantastic hope and
strength messages coming out through
those pupils at this manchester school
want ukrainian children to know they are
not forgotten children my age and
younger as well they're leaving it's
really sad and upsetting my message that
i put on the wall was for both sides
like russia and ukraine to choose
harmony instead of destruction
and um
so like for the people to stay strong
because
just imagine a week ago they were the
kids in ukraine were learning about
algebra and now the houses are being
born bombed
in a complex world walls can sometimes
divide
this one is all about support
catherine over topsy sky news in
manchester
well facebook and twitter have been
blocked in russia as the kremlin
continues its efforts to block russians
receiving independent information about
the invasion of ukraine our reporter
katie barnfield joins me from the
newsroom now and katie this has even
forced the bbc to broadcast some of its
things on the dark web
it has indeed jane good morning well
this move by the russian state
communications regulator against
facebook appears to be a retaliation for
facebook's decision to restrict access
to russian state media in countries
across europe including here in the uk
because of fears they were spreading
russian propaganda now the russian
regulator says it has decided to block
access to facebook because of 26 cases
of what it calls discrimination against
russia media outlets and says it's also
taken action against twitter because
that platform would not take down
content that had been banned by the
russian authorities now of course this
move has been widely condemned
outside of russia as yet another attempt
to block the access of civilians to
independent information about the
invasion of ukraine now the white house
has said that it is deeply concerned
about this we've also heard from metta's
global affairs president sir nick clegg
which is the company that owns facebook
he has said today
soon millions of ordinary russians will
find themselves cut off from reliable
information deprived of their everyday
ways of connecting with family and
friends and silenced from speaking out
we will continue to do everything we can
to restore our services so they remain
available to people now this is against
a backdrop of the bbc news and other
global media outlets deciding to suspend
their reporting from russia temporarily
to try and protect their journalists
because of a new law that's come in
which effectively threatens them with
jail for publishing stories that are
critical of the kremlin and as you say
this has now prompted the bbc uh to
encourage russians to access his content
on the dark web through a browser called
tour to try and get around russian state
censorship so very difficult situation
for people living in russia at the
moment are increasingly hard for them to
access accurate information about what
is happening as this war continues
katie thanks very much for bringing us
all that update
coming up next on sky news i'm going to
be joined by a journalist for the kiev
independent who despite attacks by the
russian army continues to report on the
situation on the ground
[Music]
and been heard from the center of the
capital of kiev and while the city
remains under ukrainian control a vast
russian military convoy is positioned
close by well let's talk now to asami
terejima she's a journalist reporting
for the kiev independent who is now in
la viv and really lovely to talk to you
sami we spoke at uh last week um and you
were staying in kiev you said you wanted
to but now you've moved to la viv how
was that journey and how are you
so obviously it's very it was really
difficult for me to move i left with a
happy heart because i wanted to stay in
kiev but um we don't know what the
infrastructure going to be like so i
decided to move to leve um and there's
the trains are very uh packed um there's
lots of people thousands of people
waiting at the train station because
lots of trains get cancelled and because
the train tickets are free uh it just
whoever gets in gets in so like it's so
at the platform it's really crazy
because everyone is running to the trees
as if it's the last train that there
will ever be even though we all know
that there will be more trains in the
future
and and we've heard this morning about
russia saying that it's pausing its
activities to allow uh people to leave
mario paul kind of creating a bit of a
human corridor and what are you able to
tell us about that what are the
ukrainian authorities saying
so there hasn't been a confirmation from
the ukrainian side yet
but we also need to be careful because
yes um both cities are in human
humanitarian catastrophe uh people are
hiding in the basement without food
water electricity heat and it's they're
living in a very bad condition and
they're really in need of help
but at the same time russia's strategy
initially was um targeting primarily on
military objects but now they have they
seem to be targeting a lot more on
civilians because they've been bombing
the residential uh
uh areas and it's we need to make sure
that um i mean
yes it's a we need a humanitarian
corridor but at the same time we need to
keep an eye on the situation
do you think you'll be able to go back
to kiev
i would really like to because it's a
city that i love and
i would like to report from the
epicentre of the conflict but um i also
need to continue updating the site and i
don't know about what's gonna be what's
gonna happen with the wi-fi and i'm more
of a political reporter so i don't i'm
not trained enough to really report the
combat zone
and and in terms of the future
live
obviously much safer than kiev and mario
paul but
are you concerned that that it will just
the russians will just continue to head
west and you'll be forced to move on
from where you are now even
so uh yes we don't know i mean we don't
know like what's going to happen to the
youth either i'm not concerned because
i'm more concerned about other cities
like mario paul given you know what
happened with her song russians already
like spreading its folk i
to the city uh obviously people will not
believe it but it's it's it's in a bad
country it's in a very bad condition so
i'm worried about those cities and
what's going to happen to kiev but i
live um i think it's safe for now but we
don't know what's going to happen but
i'm not as concerned about what could
happen to being other more i'm more
concerned about the situation that's
already for unfolding in these cities in
the east
and uh in kiev and you know in the north
and
your president has
appealed to the west for support with a
no-fly zone it doesn't appear to look
like it is going to happen um how do do
you feel and how do do your colleagues
feel about this
well we all expected this because we
knew that um
nato and you know also the um senior
secretary uh bring anthony brinky
wouldn't would reject this but uh at the
same time we also we also agree with uh
president eddie that it's the same as
giving a green right for further you
know russian bomb
giving a green light for russians to
further bomb ukrainian cities and
obviously we are very concerned that we
want i know enough right zone over
ukraine but it just seems to be
this seems to have like almost zero
percent of happening
um we are seeing an enormous
humanitarian effort though aren't we you
know where i am on the polish border
just so much stuff that is being donated
there's such a willingness for people to
help ukrainians which is really
heartwarming but
essentially all that the people who are
where you are and are leaving what to do
is is to go back home isn't it
yes we all want to go back home and i
spoke to people at the train station as
well and many of them were in shock uh
they want they wanted to stay here but
they don't want they don't want to go
anywhere but they know that kiev is you
know every day kiev is becoming more
dangerous and they want to many of them
have also gone back to their families in
different cities even though kiev has
become home for them uh so everyone was
living with a very heavy heart the train
station there's lots of people but
people were like more quiet because you
know they're they have they're going
through a lot and uh um yeah i also i
was also very
um it was really difficult for me as
well so we kind of all of your i think
we all felt the same thing
asami terejima stay safe and it's lovely
to talk to you again thanks very much
for joining us on sky news
um in the last few moments we've seen
the us secretary of state anthony
blinken leave brussels uh he was of
course there for nato talks yesterday
he's moving on to poland today he's
going to meet the polish foreign
minister there's a big new rao today
he's also going to be going on to
moldova after that
i'm going to hand you back to kamali in
the studio for a little while but we'll
be back at the top of the hour
absolutely right thank you very much for
that jane plenty more from the polish
border later on today all right well
jackie is here with us and of course
jackie everyone in the sporting world is
talking about
shane warren i think we might have
actually a picture of
the ball of the century again it just
blows my mind when i think about this
that was his first ball in the ashes um
it's
i still can't talk about the story
actually i can't believe that someone
who was so full of vitality and life and
looked in the shape of his life as well
you know he used to be a chubby
cricketer let's be honest and then he
suddenly you know transformed himself
[Laughter]
and it's just really hard to it was just
so hard to read that news that he died
of a heart attack on holiday um he's a
once-in-a-lifetime cricketer certainly a
once-in-a-lifetime bowler you know the
greatest leg spinner of all time the
king of spin
he is the second greatest wicket taker
of all time behind the tire mirror
uh with seven
108 test wickets and you know his record
in ash's test i mean he obviously lived
to play the ashes
um was just extraordinary the ball of
the century as you said was his was his
sort of introduction to ash's cricket
and what an amazing introduction that
was well you will you'll know that
someone like shane would have been
practicing that kind of ball with his
brothers and with his friends in the
street all his life so be able to be
able to do it the first time he goes out
in the ashes
i don't know if he did practice all his
life because he really wanted to be a
footballer he really wanted to play
aussie rules and it was the devastation
of not making it as a pro
you know player that you know turned him
on to cricket and that's when he really
sort of honed his skills and it i think
you know his sort of rise and cricket
happened really really quickly he was
just like he was just gifted you know
absolutely gifted because what he did
with the ball other people clearly
couldn't do no matter how many times
they practiced um seven years at
hampshire you know beloved by british
cricket fans not just aussie cricket
fans i mean the guy just
transcended the sport really he was a
proper proper superstar with huge
charisma and a huge aura about him i i
interviewed him a couple of years ago
before covert hit and um
although you know i'd met him a couple
of times
you chat to him for five minutes and you
feel like you've known him your whole
life he just really makes you feel very
comfortable
so friendly and i think he was he was
just a really really genuinely
nice bloke from melbourne who never ever
changed he was always the thing whether
he was hanging out the back having a [ __ ]
with the cleaners um or you know mixing
with
with royalty he was just always the same
um
i just think incredibly sad news and i
think you know for the australians
waking up to this news this morning
because it would have happened pretty
much in the middle of their night
yesterday
i mean they must be you know in shock
all over again we've pretty much had a
day to get used to it but um you know
they must be incredibly shocked um
the young players in the australian team
now obviously didn't play with him
because it was a different era but they
would definitely have had him you know
posters on their walls and they would
have tried to copy his hair and you know
the bowling action and all the rest of
it and um pat cummins was definitely one
of those players
who idolised shane
warren we all grew up watching warnie
idolising him
we had posters on his wall
had his earrings
we
we loved so much about warnie um
you know his showmanship his charisma
his tactics the way he he just willed
himself and the team around him to win
games for australia
and probably above all else his
incredible skill as leg spinner
so many
guys in this team and squad who
uh
you know still hold him as a hero their
all-time favorite player
and the loss
that we're all trying to wrap our heads
around is huge
yeah the current captain they're really
showing how upset he is by the loss of
shane i actually reached out to a lot of
players and said you know would you come
on and talk to us and you know kevin
peterson for example was like i can't
talk about that you're all cut up aren't
there you see that with my guests
yesterday
i can't talk about it it's too raw can't
i can't talk about it really such an
impact that
he had all right well look a sport and
war unfortunately mixing in ukraine with
that russian invasion i know you've been
speaking to a ukrainian tennis player
he's now picked up a rifle right yeah
we've been following his story because i
spoke to him last week he was trying to
um get back to kiev having been on a
family holiday in dubai get his family
to safety get back to kiev and he'd
signed up with the territorial army so
he wanted to get a gun and start
fighting and um sergey stakovsky um did
manage to get back to kiev caught up
with him yesterday um
and the question one of the questions i
was asking him and you can see the full
interview at 9 35 was you know have you
heard from russian
tennis players have they been in contact
with you um because you you know the
sports world
russia wise has been very very quiet
speaking out about this war apart from
the odd couple of people they've got the
world's number one tennis player haven't
they at the moment they have got the
world's number one tennis player who
they they've said a little bit but
they've said quite a little um
this is what sergey said
he actually wasn't expecting russian
players to speak out and this is why
none of them wants war but it's very
hard for them for some of them saying no
war or stop war it's already a
very thin line declaration for the
russian state it is very hard for
professional athletes to
call out the regime because they still
have relatives in that country which can
be endangered
so i cannot really ask from the tennis
players to you know come out and say
what they what they want to say it's
impossible
okay jackie for now thank you very much
for that well let's just uh bring you
some breaking news coming into us here
at sky news in the past couple of
minutes the city council of mariopol as
you understand that that's a city of
course
in the south east of ukraine that's been
under a russian encirclement for the
past few days says that they are now
beginning to evacuate citizens there was
some reporting from russian news
agencies a couple of hours ago that a
humanitarian corridor had been opened
for the city of mario paul so the city
council now saying that they're about to
start an evacuation we'll bring more
detail on that as we get it throughout
the morning but for now let's take a
look at the day's weather here
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now there'll be more rain coming to
eastern parts of england today but
sunday looks like it'll be fine and dry
it'll be a cold start for many this
weekend with a widespread frost across
ireland northern ireland and western
scotland early rain over eastern england
will become increasingly confined to
east anglia and the southeast other
eastern and central parts of england
will be great elsewhere it'll be dry
with plenty of sunshine but the odd
shower is possible northern scotland
south wales and the southwest look most
at risk from those showers it'll be
chilly and breezy under the cloud now
the afternoon will bring about little
change but more of eastern england can
expect outbreaks of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well coming up on sky news breakfast
we'll take a look at the morning's
papers with the journalists and
broadcaster apple hagan and thomas
copeland
[Music]
pleased to say that the journalists and
broadcasters for hagen and thomas
copeland are with us again uh thank you
again for being with us uh geyser af
we're gonna start with you you've picked
out a story from the daily mail which is
uh uh very close to us here at sky news
our colleagues uh coming under fire in
ukraine doing their work just take us
through what's happening the viewers do
want to see that it's on skynys.com
right now
oh absolutely so this is a report that i
saw on last night on the sky news um and
the sky news chief correspondent was out
in the field with a crew of about five
there was five people in the crew all
together and they came under fire from
what's called a russian death squad so
they were in a village um just outside
of kiev the capital uh just trying to
see what was going on there and they
came under heavy fire from this russian
deathboard and these uh death squads
have been firing at ukrainians who are
trying to leave in their cars um and i'm
not sure if they mistook this guy and
used crew for ukrainians trying to leave
or frankly they knew they were pressed
and just decided to fire on them
but they came under heavy fire everyone
in the crew now the cameraman kept
filming amazingly and what struck me
about this piece was that i'm sure they
weren't calm but they came across as
being so calm in that moment it was a
little swaying that was bleep tight but
i mean i'm sure i would have been
screaming my head off but they came
across as very calm they came under
heavy fire the bullets kept from coming
you could hear them you could see them
sparking off the ground and so the chief
correspondent and the cameramen were
both hit
but they were wearing body armor and
helmets and the five crew managed to
escape into i think a factory a
warehouse or a garage where some
mechanics were working before they were
evacuated many hours later
by the police and taken to safety and
this really brings home
how dangerous it is in the ukraine the
level of violence that the russian
forces are using and of course what
journalists in the region are facing
every single day so more power to the
crew i think it was stuart ramsey all
power to them i'm so glad that they are
safe the five crew and the five-man team
that were out in the field and you know
thank you to them for continuing to tell
the story of what's happening there but
i'm so glad that they got away safely
yeah they definitely it's uh stuart
ramsey is producer dominique
martin val's and also the cameraman
richie motley who as you said kept
recording just incredible footage as i
said viewers if you do want to see that
you'll find it on skynews.com
and thomas i mean after we mentioned it
there this just highlights the dangers
of reporting this story reporting from
an active war zone those guys are all
veterans of war zones they know how to
handle themselves but it's really
dangerous out there we've seen lots of
news of you know of journalists who are
living and working in in bomb shelters
essentially in the capital kiev it's a
really difficult situation to bring this
story to the world isn't it
yeah absolutely and actually the story i
was just going to talk about now is also
you know in domestically in russia as
well how much more difficult that
process is becoming of being a
journalist on the ground in ukraine i
can't imagine that the challenges they
face there and also the ethical
challenges facing journalists every
single day as to you know the risks that
they're putting themselves in and the
risks that pose to them and their
families and it is a duty and it is a
public service for journalists to be in
the ground in places like ukraine um and
war zones across the world and that
comes at a price and that is a price no
doubt for the family of all the people
uh or the family of all the crew that
you mentioned there sitting at home
terrified night after night for their
own family and as actually at the end of
that report acknowledged that it was
right to do so that these are
increasingly the everyday experiences of
ordinary ukrainian people it can be very
easy i suppose as a journalist or indeed
anyone in a war zone like that to sort
of place yourself at the center of that
story but what that report did so well
was ensured that it reflected the fact
that these were the everyday experiences
of of hundreds of thousands of ukrainian
people and indeed many of them are not
nearly as lucky as that particular crew
who managed to escape as if we said into
a nearby warehouse and be evacuated by
police a number of hours later so the
danger that the journalists in the
ukraine and then in russia as well are
putting themselves into
in the last yesterday just the lower
house
house of parliament in in russia the
duma pass legislation where um
journalists accused of spreading what
they call fake news could be imprisoned
for up to 15 years and as you would
expect that definition of fake news is
left entirely within the hands of the
russian authorities bbc news taking off
the air there increasingly western
broadcaster cbs cnn abc removing their
operations bbc actually placing its
russian language news site on the dark
web in in russia to facilitate that
surge of hundreds of thousands of
millions of russians attempting to
access accurate information rather than
the propaganda that is being pushed
towards them by the russian government
the russian government going to extreme
steps to attempt to prevent their own
population from finding out accurate
information by what's happening in
ukraine closing facebook closing twitter
it's extraordinary i mean russia was
never a democracy but in many ways it
was
a not a typical
um sort of middle-income european
country and in the space of you know two
weeks it has come to resemble a despotic
totalitarian regime not unlike that of
north korea um
and and
what putin clearly recognizes is the
fact that this is not a war that is
supported by ordinary russian people it
is putin's war and that may be something
that comes back to bite him in again in
the end having said that my fear is i
suppose that
does putin care does he care about what
his population think does he even care
what you know a russian oligarchs think
and what kind of impact will those
sanctions have if this is a ego driven
war on behalf of a russian dictator
purely ego and it is really he shows no
regard for human life so where he ends
with this uh who knows at this stage
right thomas southwest thank you very
much for now while you are watching sky
news breakfast do stay with us ahead in
the next hour american city council open
humanitarian corridors
[Music]
so
you